I have a fundamental issue with the  character Larry strong club foot okay  got it so clubfoot beats off to Queen  Alexis yeah he does look like he looks  like Kaiser what do you think he would  look like when he obsess it over feet  Brian looking like that what's crazy to  me is that there are people that date  women and don't even look at their feet  that's right what actually bothered me  is that shorty didn't have any toenail  polish on they didn't do polish bags  it's like 1300. they ain't even do  Contour yet bro the Kardashians were in  bonya no but what I'm saying is they  don't even give us the good shot of the  toes it's like profile from far away or  like from the bottom of what's the angle  that you want to see she takes off the  stockings yeah and then you kind of see  feed you can't see toenail length you  can't see any of these things I don't  even know if it's her feet  no what